Entonces, el sueño profundo y las ondas delta
son en realidad un marcador de juventud biológica.
Así que, naturalmente, quería dormir más profundamente
y, literalmente, probé casi todos los gadgets y dispositivos...
grado de consumidor, grado clínico,
que existen.
Aprendí mucho y descubrí que realmente necesito, como la mayoría de las personas,
ocho horas de sueño.
Incluso cambié mi componente circadiano
cambiando mis comidas, ejercicio y exposición a la luz,
pero todavía no podía encontrar una manera de dormir más profundamente...
eso es hasta que conocí al Dr. Dmitry Gerashchenko
de la Escuela de Medicina de Harvard.
Dmitry me contó sobre un nuevo hallazgo en la literatura,
de un laboratorio de Alemania que demostró que si podías tocar ciertos sonidos
en el momento correcto en el sueño de la gente,
en realidad podrías hacer durmieran más profunda y eficientemente.
Y es más, este laboratorio mostró
que podría mejorar el rendimiento de la memoria del día siguiente
con este sonido.
Dmitry y yo hicimos equipo,
y comenzamos a trabajar en una forma de construir esta tecnología.
Con nuestros colaboradores del laboratorio de investigación en Penn State
diseñamos experimentos para validar nuestro sistema.
Y desde entonces hemos recibido fondos de la National Science Foundation
y el Instituto Nacional de Salud
para desarrollar esta tecnología estimulante del sueño profundo.
Así es cómo funciona.
La gente entra al laboratorio
y la conectamos a una serie de dispositivos,
dos de los cuales tengo aquí mismo...
no es una representación de moda.
(Risas)
Cuando detectamos que las personas duermen profundamente,
tocamos los sonidos estimulantes del sueño profundo
que mostraron que ocasionan tener un sueño más profundo.
Voy a mostrarles este sonido ahora mismo.
(Repetición de las ondas de sonido)
Bastante raro, ¿verdad?
(Risas)
Ese sonido está en realidad
en la misma frecuencia de ráfagas que las ondas cerebrales
cuando el cerebro está en un sueño profundo.
Ese patrón de sonido realmente prepara la mente
para que tenga más de estas ondas delta regenerativas.
Al preguntarles a los participantes al otro día sobre los sonidos,
no sabían que tocábamos sonidos,
sin embargo, sus cerebros respondieron con más de estas ondas delta.
Aquí una imagen de las ondas cerebrales de alguien del estudio que realizamos.
¿Ven el panel inferior?
Muestra el sonido que se reproduce a esa frecuencia de ráfaga.
Ahora miren las ondas cerebrales en la parte superior del gráfico.
Pueden ver en el gráfico
que el sonido, en realidad, causa más de estas ondas delta regenerativas.
Aprendimos que podíamos seguir con precisión el sueño
sin conectar personas a electrodos
y hacer que la gente durmiera más profundamente.
Seguimos desarrollando
el ambiente de sonido correcto y el hábitat de sueño
para mejorar la salud del sueño de las personas.
Nuestro sueño no es tan regenerativo como podría ser,
pero tal vez un día pronto,
podríamos usar un pequeño dispositivo
y saca más provecho de nuestro sueño.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)